what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
discussing the latest big reveal in the
black Lawler story the identity of the
demonic rulers of the Spade kingdom the
names and faces of the next major
villains are now finally out in the open
and things are heating up quickly in the
story of black clover in fact it seems
that some extremely interesting plot
twists and battles are coming very soon
and I can't wait to talk about it all
right here in this video if you enjoy
our black clover content please leave a
like to let me know it really does help
and if you happen to be new to anime
abroad don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications you can also hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
finally this video will contain black
clover manga spoilers I'm dealing with
the latest developments in the story so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned the action starts off right
away as noelle makes her glorious toon
that grand entrance in the aftermath of
lost us black slashing of the entire
spate army inside the mobile fortress
Noelle arrives in her Valkyrie dress
armor and she is using her water magic
to carry mimosa and Finn roll inside a
big magical ball of water not
surprisingly Noelle calls hasta an idiot
several times meanwhile Aust
acknowledges that Noelle is even cooler
now after their six months of training
and I'm sure this means that she is also
much stronger now as well Noelle is all
like hasta you idiot
how dare you leave without me but on the
inside she's all like I wanted to go
with you I love you so much hasta you're
so hot and manly not a direct quote but
I am paraphrasing you know what they say
once you go black ah stop you never go
back anyway now that Finn Roland Ramones
are also there Finn role is totally 100%
not into any other girls and he is only
interested in lady finesse
seriously though funeral is still Finn
role but he is definitely making
progress he is now able to stop him
solved from fawning over other women
without meaning to be told to by others
and even asked acknowledges that finra
has gotten stronger fin Rollins also
officially engaged to finesse now so
clearly the man is working to get his
life in order mad respect
mimosa then uses her plant healing magic
to heal the physical injuries of all the
civilians inside the mobile fortress and
just from that one panel we can see that
my Moses abilities have also improved
drastically in these past six months
thanks in large part to her training
with the heart Kingdom spirit Guardians
this new spell is called soothing
princess flower paradise according to
some translations and it appears to be a
spell that works on a much grander scale
than her previous spells as it is able
to heal dozens of people at once this
chapter and the previous chapter are
really showcasing how much stronger our
heroes have become and while this is
cool because it means that they are
going to be using crazy new spells and
epic power-ups part of the reason why
the heroes had to get so much stronger
is that the new villains the Spade
kingdom's rulers and the demon Meggie
Kula appear to be incredibly overpowered
the civilians on board the mobile
fortress are grateful to mimosa for
healing them but they say that they
can't go back to their hometown because
it has been occupied by the spade
military it won't do them much good to
return if they're just gonna be taken
back into custody and end up in the same
situation as before but as it turns out
Locke voltea and Leopold Vermillion have
already been dispatched to the hometown
of the civilians and boy did Locke and
Leopold ever deliver when it comes to
taking out the Spade military seeing
luck and Leo just crushing the spade
soldiers with their lightning and fire
magic is like music for your eyes
absolutely beautiful luck then uses a
magical communication device which looks
a lot like one of those Holograms from
Star Wars to inform hasta and the others
back at the mobile fortress that they
have successfully liberated the hometown
of the civilians from the Spade army
hasta is apparently jealous at how much
taller Leo has gotten in the past
six months and he informs the civilians
that finra liz going to transport them
back to their hometown where they will
be free to do as they wish in peace
the civilians are extremely grateful and
asked of vows to travel into the spade
kingdom in order to defeat the demon
mcgee Kula the civilian girl from the
previous chapter informs Aastha that the
spade kingdom is currently being ruled
by a dark triad or triumvirate basically
a trio of evil magic users who are said
to be so strong that they are like
demons themselves at that point the
chapter takes us to the cold and snowy
heart of the Spade kingdom where the
three evil rulers are sitting around the
table and talking this part of the
chapter is extremely interesting so I
will be breaking it down at length I am
so excited that the major villains have
finally been revealed and their brief
conversation gives us some really
important clues about demon magic and
the future of this arc one of the three
is named Dante and he calls out to
another one named xenon and asks him
whether he has gotten used to using the
demons power Zenon replies that he more
or less has and we now know that Zenon
was the one who easily wrecked the
entire diamond Kingdom army by himself
the third ruler is a woman named von
eeka who calls Dante her big brother and
she laments that she hasn't had the
chance to do anything big yet with her
newfound power
apparently this trio was also waiting
for six months for everything to be
prepared and now it is time for them to
get moving by the way for those of you
who might be confused xenon is the one
with messy hair who was shown invading
the diamond kingdom back in Chapter two
to seven Vanek ax is the woman who wears
a tiara and an eyepatch and Dante is the
one who wears a large crown Dante says
that it would have been boring if they
didn't wait six months because the game
would be over right away to me this
really sounded like the trio is fully
aware of what Austin the crew have been
up to
it's as if they wanted them to get
stronger just so they could pose a
worthy challenge
the trio if this is true and the trio is
already fully aware of everything that
the heart and clover kingdoms have been
planning then this entire Spade kingdom
war arc might turn out to be worse for
us than friends than they could have
ever predicted based on the knowledge
that they have right now the chapter
ends as dante proclaims that all the
life is in the palms of their hands and
the trio wonders where they should
attack first there is a lot to unpack
here in terms of these three brand new
characters they are clearly the rulers
of the Spade Kingdom what with the
Crown's and everything and they may all
be siblings because Wanaka called dante
her big brother so this might be the
royal family of the Spade Kingdom
although it is notable that Zenon does
not wear a crown we already know that
these guys are incredibly strong we've
seen a demonstration of Xenon's power
before the time skip and he was so
strong that he not only defeated the
entire Diamond Kingdom army but he also
managed to actually frighten the
electric mad lad Locke voltea himself so
based on that alone we can expect these
three to be more than a match for the
newly powered up hasta and Cru we also
know from their brief conversation that
these three are using demon power Dante
had asked Zenon if he had gotten used to
using the demons power so that confirms
that these guys are working directly
with Meggie Kula the only question is
how exactly are these guys connected to
the demon is Zenon using the demons
power in the same way that hasta is
using the power of the demon inside his
grimoire or is Miggy Kula possessing
Zenon or are we talking about some other
form of demonic power perhaps McGee Kula
special ability is not to only drained
amount of others on mass but also to
allow certain individuals to use some of
his own demonic powers perhaps McGee
Kula can allow all three rulers of the
Spade Kingdom to use a portion of his
power which makes all three of them as
strong as a demon or maybe there are
multiple demons involved here and each
member of the trio is using a
different demons power although that is
less likely because Meggie Kula is the
only demon that has been mentioned so
far
if theoretically there were three
separate demons involved why would the
Hart and clover kingdoms only be aware
of the existence of one of them don't
get me wrong it is possible that there
are multiple demons in the picture but
so far we have no concrete evidence that
there is anyone else other than Meggie
Kula the other fascinating thing about
the three rulers of spade are the dark
marks on their faces Zenon has a large
cross shaped mark on the left side of
his forehead that stretches down over
his eye dante has a frankenstein esque
mark that stretches across his forehead
and Vanek ax doesn't have a visible mark
but it is quite possible that her mark
is hidden somewhere behind her large eye
patch
these marks kind of remind me of the
star-shaped mark that used to be on
Julius's forehead we now know that
Julius was using the star-shaped mark
also known as the Swallowtail crest to
store his time magic for later use and
the mark eventually disappeared after he
used it to bring himself back from the
dead this makes me wonder whether these
marks on the faces of the dark triad are
similar forms of ancient magic as the
Swallowtail crest and whether they can
be used to either store magic or make
the users stronger in some way or
perhaps these marks are something
different maybe they're just signs that
all three Spade rulers have been marked
by a demon and that they are using the
demon's power after all we know that
when someone is cursed by the demon the
curse leaves a large black mark on them
as we saw on beaver girl's abdomen so
maybe this is something like that but
instead of a curse mark this is a
possession mark or a demon power boost
mark after all
hasta in his black hasta form also gets
dark marks on his face and body so this
could be just a more permanent demonic
mark that appeared once the three gained
the ability to use demonic powers
whatever the mark means these three new
villains are absolutely fascinating we
know they're extremely powerful
we know they can use the
and powers and we know that they are
planning a massive attack we also know
that even though Austin France have
gotten a lot stronger in these past few
months the dark trio from the Spade
Kingdom seems to have been expecting
this and they seem to be deliberately
waiting for the Hart and clover kingdoms
to get stronger this implies that the
spade kingdom rulers have already
formulated a master plan and that Austin
Noel luck and everyone else may be
heading right into the spade kingdom's
demonic trap this is definitely a really
interesting escalation of the current
arc and we have a great set up for an
epic conflict between heroic power ups
and the sinister demonic magic of the
Spade Kingdom I can't wait to learn more
about the ruling trio of the Spade
Kingdom and about the demon Meggie Kula
let me know what you guys think did you
enjoy the reveal of xenon Dante and
vantika and do you have high
expectations of these guys as villains
or do you think that these three are
just mere stepping stones to the real
villain the demon McGee Koala himself
feel free to hit me up down in the
comments below if you enjoyed this video
and you want us to keep it going please
leave a like to let me know and if you
have it to be new to the channel please
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications you could also follow me
on twitter and instagram at anime uproar
i want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime upper patrons for supporting
our work and making videos like this one
possible special thank you to all of our
pro hero to your patrons including the
one and only gilgamesh baby rain nothing
but a fan Jason Wilson King's eldress
$30 beat a garage Ian Anatole Cassatt's
key DJ Nathaniel alpha DL and on hell
Cruz and of course I can't forget our
the one tier patrons the ones who stand
above all other clans including Ingrid
ah a lowland out of Maddy Mac makoto-kun
Seth Cooper and the world and you know
he's serious because he didn't say so
wild all if you enjoy our videos and you
feel that they provide value for you
please consider becoming a patron even a
single dollar will give you access to
our patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as all
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see us space cowboys
[Music]